for
[Music]
um careful you have like arm PS so
you're you're trying to do technique or
something trying to do a move over
again uh let I always let him he does
whatever it's just ever so slightly he
has like a a down there's more pressure
on this hand and there's a in okay so I
reconcile that
one and do that again okay so ever so
slightly I felt a down there's a
downward to it and there's an inwardness
to it and there was more pressure on
this hand okay so you see that I
yielding to
that he he's he's pushing me this way
cuz that hand coming this way so that's
why he goes that way you see he pushed
my hands there I don't I can't I don't
know where he's going to go till I feel
where he's going to go so that's why I
say he he pushed me there that's why I
say I let him move my hands there I'm
not trying to go like this okay he move
my hands there then that extra pressure
that he had here that's the pressure
that I
you guys see that so cuz some of you are
like you're going here and you're like
oh this did something different than
that last M where that one worked you
see cuz you just have this move where
you're going to go like that to everyone
you see that and then maybe he's he's
heavier or he's pushing down more or he
can get way more leverage on you you see
for what you're doing so as you're
trying to combine is you like get stuck
here okay instead he he goes where he
is you can see the heavier hand I used
for the projection hand do do you guys
understand
that and then remember that even if you
get stuck here it won't rebound you
until you
tense in the same way that you're out
here and you
relax at that moment you could you could
do all this stuff out
here as long as you're relaxed well the
same thing this won't cause problems
till you till you get tense and usually
you're getting tense because your
choreography you you notice it's not
going to work and then you get tense
okay but if you just feeling
it more and more
relax that doesn't matter if you want to
turn you can
hold come out slow this doesn't become a
problem to you go not
working you can always come here open up
too there's no reason
why you get what I going to slow down I
got here and now here's where I open up
yield one way project if I need to take
some Mass off of him
okay it's just even if it's slight
you're like not working you got him and
you don't even let's say even less I
don't move but I felt the tension I
don't want that okay or I felt my weight
go to my heels I don't want that before
that
happens yield at the end except at the
end even there but if you move away from
choreography and you're just just in a
relationship with
him it'll
work okay try it
all right the the training is kind of
counterintuitive for B in that you're
like goal oriented so you're like I
moved
him I moved him that that's not it the
training is skill development so uh
parameters are set yes move him but it's
how you're moving him okay and how is
determined by certain metrics that you
have so one of them is midfoot I
mentioned that in the last break so if I
felt heel weight you see even if I was
able to move him I would go no that's
not correct okay another one is your
feet
moving your feet don't
move your feet stay exactly like the
they are
now don't let them wiggle on
you they stay exactly like they are
now bring some awareness to what your
feet are
doing to where your weight is which we
already
mentioned if you can bring that
awareness up to your
calves feel no tension
there if you can come up through the
groins to the
glutes okay we are now
don't let them wiggle on
you they stay exactly like they are
now bring some awareness to what your
feet are
doing to where your weight is which
which we already
mentioned if you can bring that
awareness of to your
calves feel no tension
there if you can come up through the
groins to the
glutes okay
all right so
um let's try to try to remember
this the arm arm is very very difficult
it happens but it's so low
percentage
um and it's
why when we deconstruct the posture
that's why my projection line is through
the center not not on the arms not in
the shoulders okay so there's a lot you
know you you'll have like I'll come into
the shoulders do you see I'm in the
shoulders and yes he's on his toes do
you do you get it uh and then you'll
have throws from here like people will
do throws okay I just I it doesn't
duplicate in in if we were actually
fighting so as he's fighting right
there's no I'm not going to get in his
shoulders and try to get that do you get
it but I can get in his
Center you guys understand do you
understand yes okay so uh there's really
no Marsh I mean I guess there is if
you're trying to take control of the
guy's arms and shoulders uh but you get
way more control if you're in the center
okay just martially speaking but
um in terms of what I want to do
energetically Al chemically this it
doesn't do anything for me okay so what
we want to do is not be in your
shoulders even even if I'm projecting
into your
shoulders I always
have to feel your
Center so I shouldn't ever have your
shoulders
up and I'm doing that here's that same
move but lower you see that so same move
shoulders St move lower you guys see
that okay so it doesn't matter what if
you're doing the yield don't come up in
his shoulder on this hand you don't
don't pull the shoulder you pull the
[Music]
center so don't go in his
shoulders same thing
Center same thing High I'm my hands are
high but it's low you feel that okay
high low okay and you can see ever so
slightly his shoulders going up his
shoulders going
down you have to always feel for
that it should always be a slight little
CR crunch somewhere in there where you
have it slight little crunch before the
projection don't leave this free
floating and you're up here like
that always
crunch crunch
it doesn't matter which one you do
crunch
crunch you yeld a lot there's a
crunch okay and even on your projection
line when I have this hand this hand
here don't go up the
shoulder this hand goes into that that
same
Center so a lot of you are getting this
yield but then you're pushing his
shoulder is it pushable
yes but you want to go
here
Center
Center okay you guys see that stay out
the shoulders then you're more likely
stay out of your shoulders okay try
it then you yielded with your elbows
your head on the
yield elbow on the right you're late
that means you're late on the
yield early on the
yield keep going
late elbow
bend elbow bent laid on the
yield early on the
yield uh if you two got it I don't want
you projecting hard into her
Center um so what I mean is you're
intellectualizing it you're late and
then you have to bend your elbow see
well my hand should stay in in
katat okay so even as I as I'm moving
there's the one I did on Andrew you see
there that was the projection point you
see that yes well if I un that's just
the inward spiral if I unwind
it it's the same elbow Bend you see yeah
yes okay so I don't have to go
here I keep the same
Bend okay same
then same
then what I'm not going to go go back
please
early so how do I stop being
late how do I stop being early is I let
you touch my
hands you you touch my hands there you
go you touch my
hands you
tou even if I
go closer to my body it doesn't matter
you P my
you
touch not
predicting and not getting
smashed you touch
my and if you pay attention
uh what's instinctual to me is
eventually I just reached for you so I I
started that on Andrew and I started
just doing it on you so I'm not I'm not
here I start as we start
going there's a little grip counter in
there and I can't do that if I'm late or
predicting okay all right try
it okay so uh a lot of you are having
this hand come down like your your yield
hand so you go here and then then you're
projecting this hand doesn't just go
here this hand sticks so he could go the
other way you see it it has to stick has
to move
him you guys thought that and so a lot
of times it's going dead because you're
like got you you you come here on
the projection line but it's dead okay
and instead this is if we go back to my
what I eventually start doing
I'm here you see and it's stick sticking
sticking okay so if you don't if you
leave it in the grip it still has to do
it it still has to do it so even though
it looks like it's here it's it's
not it's sticking inside no different
than if you're if you're out here and
you're
sticking sticking or no different on the
project ection hand the projection hand
can't go through it has to stick so that
it has the projection
point so obviously in the yinong world
there's going to be some I in the C you
see that and in the in the yield in the
external yield there has to be an
internal aspect too so even though
you're
dropping and then the more you have
that you don't have to make the big
yelds so I'm going to show you what I'm
did as I'm here and I stick there it is
and I turn that was it there's the Tilt
okay here's that rotating axle in the
spiral and keep thean and here's the
perpendicular projection line in the
center you guys see that so you're just
here and
just okay but it's all because even
though my arm is moving externally
through space inside the grip I don't
move it irrelevant of these internal
aspects okay all right try
[Music]
e
e for